et nous sommes en compagnie de jaar un
vestiaire analyste géopolitique
fondateurs du web magazine le monde
décrypté il m'arrive calme et présidente
de l'association wild et gol bonsoir à
tous les deux et merci d'être avec nous
ce soir sur arte france la déclaration
finale de ce g20 est donc attendu demain
jour du lancement rappelle de la coop 26
on a le sentiment d'une énième réunion
des dirigeants de ce monde pourrait nous
évoquer à nouveau le réchauffement
climatique avec toujours cette même
dramaturgie à quoi est-ce que ça sert
mancka mais qu'est ce que vous attendez
des dirigeants des 20 plus grandes
puissances
comme ça a été très bien rappelé dans
votre documentaire dans votre
présentation c'est essentiellement sur
eux que repose la responsabilité des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre or il
ya quelques jours antonio guterres est
donc le secrétaire général de l'onu a
rappelé que nous étions sur une très
mauvaise trajectoire qui nous emmenait
directement vers
2,7 degrés de réchauffement climatique
et donc il est plus que temps
d'améliorer d'encourager nos états
évidemment à agir mais surtout de faire
un fort raquer pour pour changer en fait
de trajectoire puisque là on se dirige
vers + 16 % d'émissions de gaz y fêtait
alors qu'on doit aller vers moins 40
d'ici deux ans d'ici à 2030 pardon
expliquez-nous de votre côté gérard est
pierre pourquoi est ce que c'est si
important que le g20 se mettent d'accord
sur une position commune concernant le
climat juste avant le lancement de la
coop 26
écoutez je pense qu'il faut s'inspirer
de ce qui se passe dans le domaine
économique n'est ce pas on a vu tout à
l'heure qu'il y avait un accord sur la
taxation des multinationales donc il y à
des cibles précises des taux précis et
un calendrier précis et ce qui semble
manquer dans le domaine climatique c'est
qu'il y a pas apparemment d'objectifs
intermédiaires n'est ce pas on parle de
réduction d'émissions de carbone pour
zéro émission de carbone à 2050 2060
mais ça c'est très loin et donc il y as
me semble-t-il absence
d'étape intermédiaire absence
d'objectifs soit par région soit par
pays mais qu'il y ait une gestion de ce
progrès vers l'objectif souhaité parce
que là ça permet de faire des points
mais autrement on est comme vous laisse
le souligner dans des incantations ou
dans des sous et il est nécessaire de
passer à une gestion qui est très
compliqué parce que les situations sont
très différentes d'un pays par rapport à
l'autre des situations climatiques rien
à voir entre l'arabie saoudite et la
russie mais pourtant le saoudien moyens
et le russe moyen consomme deux fois
plus d'énergie que le français moyen une
stratégie commune à l'échelle du g20
marinca mais c'est ce que vous attendez
un signal fort de la part des vingt
dirigeants les plus puissants du monde
parce que sans ça c'est là comme 26 qui
peut-être beaucoup en ce sens
alors que cette coop 26 c'est aussi un
premier rendez vous c'est à dire que
depuis l'accord de paris les états ont
dû re déposer leurs engagements
c'est-à-dire leur feuille de route
justement pour dire où ils en sont 50
plus tard et mettre à jour leur
contribution au niveau individuel ça
devient état par état donc en fait
normalement il devrait s'agir d'une part
de l'heure du bilan mais aussi de leurs
de se fixer l'heure de se fixer de
nouveaux objectifs
or on le voit et parlons de la france
nous avons été condamné il ya quelques
mois si ce n'est un semaine dans la
sphère du siècle dans la sphère grande
synthe parce que la justice a constaté
que la france n'avait pas tenu ses
engagements climatiques et donc
évidemment nous ne pouvons que engage
enfin
avons avancé en fait dans une meilleure
trajectoire parce que pour le moment on
est loin du compte la justice nous le
dit les citoyens le dise même les
instances comme le haut conseil pour le
climat le dise et donc aujourd'hui il
faut évidemment absolument que les
gouvernements se rendent compte que le
gouvernement d' emmanuel macron mais
aussi que l'ensemble des gouvernements
du g20 arrête de s'auto congratuler et
passe à de vraies actions
le chef du gouvernement italien mario
draghi a plaidé début octobre pour un
engagements du g20 sur la nécessité de
limiter la hausse des températures à 1,5
degré c'est l'objectif le plus ambitieux
de l'accord de paris à quel engagement
est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à un
vestiaire
écouté voilà le problème c'est que c'est
un objectif n'est ce pas planétaire et
il n'y a pas vraiment de chemin pratique
pour aller ensemble ou bien chacun de
son côté vers cet objectif là c'est
vraiment une difficulté de gestion année
après année on fait des photos comme
vient de le dire notre interlocutrice on
fait des photos mais on ne dit pas vers
quelle photo on doit attendre l'année da
suivante ou l'année d'après la faute au
général c'est 2050 ou 2060 voyez vous il
ya un groupe de pays à l'arabie saoudite
la chine et la russie qui milite en
faveur de zéro émission 2050 et puis
vous avez l'europe et les états unis qui
sont faits pour un schéma zéro émission
2050 dix ans d'écart donc il ya besoin
d'avoir une organisation mondiale
peut-être que l'onu peut dans ses
nombreuses instances y participer ou
d'autres structures internationales mais
d'avoir une vision générale accepté et
des étapes intermédiaires est à minima
une calme est un bon signal envoyé par
le g20 ce frère
densité à ralentir l'augmentation des
températures sous ce tout simplement
ah non je pense pas du tout je pense que
ça serait vraiment au contraire d'une
certaine manière dire ça y est la
bataille est perdue et on va se
contenter d'en faire le minimum c'est
d'ailleurs la position qu'a eut
publiquement boris johnson donc ça va
dans le sens de ce que vous disiez c'est
à dire on en fait le minimum personne
n'est sur la même longueur d'onde on
n'arrive pas à accorder nos violons
c'est très inquiétant parce que on a
besoin non seulement que les états
prennent des engagements mais parce que
aussi on a besoin que cela modifie
considérablement l'état d'esprit dans
lequel sont les grandes entreprises les
multinationales y a pas de raison qu'on
arrive à se mettre d'accord sur une
taxation mondiale et pas sur un accord
climatique qui permettrait de sauver
l'existence et la base le fondement sur
lequel reposent nos conditions
d'existence je pense que là vraiment
c'est d'un point de vue la compréhension
du public de ce qui se joue au g20 alors
que gas cette urgence dramatique planeta
on est en train de s'accorder sur une
taxe mondiale qui est certes importante
mais qui à l'échelle de l'ange
planétaire malheureusement aujourd'hui
on envoie un signal inquiétant je trouve
mais alors jusqu'à quel point j'ai un
respect à ce que les leaders de ces
grandes puissances économiques mondiales
sont ils prêts à s'engager pour par
exemple abandonné le charbon on pense
notamment à la chine vous l'évoquiez la
chine premier pollueur de la planète on
pense aussi à beaucoup de pays émergents
qui dépendent eux aussi encore
énormément de cette énergie fossile avec
très émettrices de co2 est indispensable
au style pour faire tourner leurs
centrales électriques et dans ce
contexte c'est le rappel de crise
énergétique quelle est leur post y
faisait vraiment la question de fondre
et comment réduire la production et
l'utilisation de charbon est donc là il
n'y a absolument rien de magique parce
que il s'agit d'instituer une 1re au
déploiement dans ce parc de la source
donc par quelle source va t-on remplacé
ces millions de tonnes de charbon est là
encore il n'ya pas vraiment une lyon
commune on retourne dans ce toujours
dans ce même travers n'est ce pas il y à
une organisation du g20 il y à une
organisation mondiale de la santé mais
pourquoi n'y aurait-il pas une
organisation mondiale du climat beaucoup
plus je dirais à incitatives beaucoup
plus coercitives que ne peut être le
programme
actuel autour des codes et est donc même
au niveau je dirais des spécialistes là
c'est un autre volet c'est qu'il n'y a
pas forcément d'accord il n'y a pas
d'accord forcément sûr et bien le bien
fondé des éoliennes il y a des avantages
des inconvénients dans le programme
éolien il y a des avantages et des
inconvénients dans le programme
nucléaire il y a des avantages des
inconvénients dans les cellules solaires
les panneaux solaires donc voyez vous il
ya aussi une absolue nécessité qu'il y
ait un une vision technologique qui soit
acceptée est acceptable et bien sûr on
peut finir par la cerise sur le gâteau
c'est le nucléaire le nucléaire est un
élément indispensable
de l'abaissement du 2 du co2 dans l'air
le les centrales nucléaires ne
produisent que de la vapeur d'eau alors
si on veut être complet effectivement
elle réchauffe légèrement l'eau de
refroidissement mais ce n'est qu'à tout
petit désavantage par rapport à l'énorme
avantage que constitue donc production
d'électricité vous évoquez à marine
fermée tout à l'heure la trajectoire
actuelle pour atteindre la neutralité
carbone d'ici 2050 c'est un prérequis
qui est indispensable pour espérer
limiter le réchauffement en dessous du
seuil de 1,5 degré vous vous nous dise
et qu'on en est donc loin il y a donc
urgence à rhône mobilisés ces arts musée
le monde sur l'enjeu climatique et c'est
ce que vous attendez aussi du g20
je pense qu'il faut un signal fort parce
que politiquement on a eu par exemple
les révélations il ya quelques jours sur
la politique du doute financé par total
depuis les années 70 pour nier l'impact
du réchauffement climatique
on a eu toutes ces informations qui sont
sortis qui était connue fête dans tout
le monde se doutait puisque aujourd'hui
les rapports du giec petit à petit on
éclaire et notamment les milieux
scientifiques mais aussi l'ensemble des
populations mondiales sur l'état
d'avancement du changement climatique
donc ce coup de rappel politique il est
important parce qu'il faut sonner la fin
de la récré à la fois du côté des
gouvernements se mettre d'accord pour
agir ensemble mais aussi du côté des
entreprises qui sont responsables on le
sait aujourd'hui d'une grande part des
émissions de gaz à effet serre et le
changement ne se fera pas sans elle mais
pour encadrer les entreprises encore une
fois et pour éviter un dumping social et
écologique c'est-à-dire le fait que des
entreprises choisissent des états moins
regardants de la question climatique ou
environnemental pour délocaliser leur
production ailleurs comme c'est
aujourd'hui le cas en chine il faut
absolument qu'il ya un accord entre les
états pour que ce dumping
environnemental ne puisse pas avoir lieu
et que l'on mette un terme de manière
coordonnée aux émissions de gaz à effet
de serre parce que sinon c'est toujours
la course à qui profite encore du vide
juridique ou du vide écologique de la
tolérance de certains états et de
certaines populations à les activités
polluantes et ça aujourd'hui il faut y
mettre un terme définitivement mais j'ai
du mal à croire que justement on arrive
vraiment aujourd'hui au g20 à faire ce
genre de choix et envoyer de ce genre de
message alors il ya aussi cette question
du financement de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique gérer un
vestiaire et on imagine ce n'est pas une
mince affaire l'enjeu c'est quoi c'est
d'aider les pays en développement à la
fois réduire leurs émissions et à
s'adapter aux conséquences du changement
climatique on imagine que le sujet est
loin de faire consensus autour de la
table du g20
tout à fait en plus il y as deuxième
volet n'est ce pas c'est que la
révolution énergétique à laquelle nous
travaillons et bien elle est porteuse
d'une révolution géopolitique c'est à
dire que la l'énergie propre va être
produite doors of à partir de maintenant
depuis quelques années elle est produite
sur les lieux de consommation les
centrales nucléaires sont près des
utilisateurs électricité les centres les
fermes d'éoliennes sont près des
consommateurs
les centrales solaires sont pas des des
consommateurs les usines productrice
d'hydrogène seront près des
consommateurs
donc on a une fantastique
fantastic
révolution parce que actuellement notre
énergie venant du sol et du sous-sol du
charbon du pétrole et du gaz se trouve
là où la terre a créé ces réserves est
donc l ces réserves sont loin des lieux
de consommation dont kylie a d'abord un
financement pour instituer effectivement
ces nouvelles sources de production
d'énergie mais il faudra aussi tenir
compte de lui des clashs et les grands
producteurs d'énergies fossiles de leurs
ressources n'est ce pas que va faire le
nigeria avec 250 ou 300 millions
d'habitants avec moins de pétrole que va
faire l'algérie avec moins de pétrole
que va faire la russie avec moins de
pétrole n'est ce pas donc il ya là des
enjeux qui sont encore plus importants
que d'aider des pays africains par
exemple à venir à une énergie propre un
tout dernier mot très rapidement avec
vos marine bien calme mais si vous le
voulez bien parce que le temps fier
alors on le voit bien les signaux
positifs
sont pas tous au rendez-vous mais malgré
tout est ce que vous direz qu'il est
quand même une avancée depuis la coop 21
il y a cinq ans la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique visiblement est
un sujet qui continue de rassembler
peut-être l'un des seul sujet qui fait
que tout le monde se réunit autour de la
table pour pour l'évoquer pour se
pencher sur ce sur ce point là est-ce
que c'est porteur d'espoir malgré tout
j'ai envie de relativiser parce que
j'avoue que ce qui me rassure le plus
c'est finalement aujourd'hui
l'engagement des nouvelles générations
c'est l'engagement des citoyens c'est
les marches climat c'est les centaines
de recours en justice climatique à
travers le monde ça ça me rassure parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un sujet qui est
éminemment politique les jeunes montent
au créneau mais aussi les jeune et ça
c'est ce qui est important parce qu'en
fait on va avoir des élections
électorales qui arrive cette année je
pense que justement la question de
l'écologie va être à droite comme à
gauche au centre de tous les débats et
de tous les programmes politiques c'est
bien qu'il ya un marqueur aujourd'hui
culturel on a atteint une certaine heure
un certain consensus sur le fait que la
question climatique ne peut plus être
mise de côté et donc pour moi c'est ça
le mot d'ordre c'est on continue on
reste mobilisé et on avance on continue
à faire pression surtout sur le segment
vernement merci beaucoup aux marines
d'un calme est présidente de
l'association wild & gold merci à vous
aussi gerin vesper analyste géopolitique
fondateurs du web magazine le monde
décrypté merci d'avoir participé à cet
échange sur un tir français et à très
bientôt sur notre antenne